for
okay folks time to
begin um two quick announcements first
is I'm not going to nag you about have
you picked a company but here's what I'm
going to do at the end of class today
now actually I'll give you a couple of
hours after the end of class I'm going
to go into that Master list no you know
I can see the master list right and I'm
going to take all those people who don't
have a company name next to their name
and I'm going to email it won't be a mad
email I'll say look you know I think
this slipped your mind can you go in and
fill in the name of your company to the
master list so if you don't want that
email just go in and put in the name of
your company right now within with right
after the class ends so it is in there
in the master list second is what's
coming a week from
now it's your first qu so let me talk a
little bit about logistics it will be in
the first 30 minutes of class so if
there's a class you're going to be late
for that is not the class right you come
in 15 minutes late it's half the quiz
gone it's going to be from 3:30 to 4:00
there will be a second room that I've
reserved for the quiz and here's why
there about 300 people in this class and
you all open up your books your notes
and your laptops God help us there's not
enough room so I'm going to get a 100 of
you shunted off that's not the right
word but you know you know what I mean
move to a different room so I'll send
you notifications of which room you're
going to be it's based on alphab where
you are in the alphabetical order I'm
not playing favorites I'll try to figure
out a way where each of you ends up
rotating at least once through that room
cuz some of you might prefer that room
to this one so don't come to me I like
that room can I go there so I will just
rotate through so you will get an email
specifying which room to go to for your
quiz and please try to go to that room
so first 30 minutes if you have extra
time you have you know other
arrangements work through the Moses
Center because they can they can arrange
all of that much better than I can any
questions about the
quiz did you read the email I sent last
night act like you did even I know by
now youve blocked me completely but I
did mention I have extra office hours
this week 9:15 to 10:15 1215 to 115
Monday Wednesday but on Sunday the day
before the quiz I'll have a two hours
Zoom office hours right nobody wants to
come here at 5:00 on a Sunday night but
by then you should have work through
stuff if you have questions that still
remain after you work through the
problems and the solutions be 5: to 7:
on Sunday T be a little late because I'm
going to be in Portugal and I'm coming
back on like 1:30 in the afternoon on
Sunday hopefully the flight lands on
time I get back to my you know to a
computer in time but plan on that as
extra office hours in case you have
questions of course the ta have review
sessions so if you need to use that
please do so as well they'll go through
past quizes any other logistical
questions so what can you bring to the
quiz you can bring open book open Notes
open displays you can even open your
laptop what's the one thing you're not
allowed to do no Excel right other than
that and it's not because Excel was
going to help you this is a quiz where
the numbers are simple enough that you
could probably do them in your head it's
just to prevent the logistics of having
200 open computers people trying to
enter Excel it'll actually slow you down
trying to do it so I'm doing you a favor
even though it doesn't sound like it so
it's a very 2025 version of open book
open Notes so you want to write
everything on one page because that's
how you usually do open book open do so
okay it's up to
you so today we're going any other
questions on the on the quiz of the exam
now one final thing if you're going to
miss the quiz what do you have to
do you have to let me know before the
quiz not after the quiz but before the
quiz simple reason I can't give you the
option of taking the quiz slipping the
quiz into your notes and saying I never
took the quiz I have no way of knowing
this way if you're going to miss the
quiz I know ahead of the time so if
you're going to if you're going to do it
at least come up with a good reason I'm
not going to ask for a doctor's note
covid is always a good reason no I've
have covid how do I know that you don't
right I can't come around with a covid
test and don't send me pictures of covid
test I'm not interested I will take you
at your word hey but remember if you can
take the quiz you should for two reasons
one is it'll force you to prepare the
for the material which you will need
anywhere for the final exam second is
you get the option of throwing away the
worst quiz and replacing with the
average score if you do all three
quizzes that's strong encourage you to
take the quiz as long as you don't have
some other commitment that is truly
going to take away from that
time so let's continue with our
discussion and today we're going to
finish up cash flows and start on growth
rates okay so one of the first questions
I'm going to ask you is about the
magnitude of growth and how it affects
your value so I'm going to ask you a
question if you have a calculator you
can help me out here after we've
answered the question
let's say you have revenues of 200
million this is an old problem LinkedIn
revenues of 200 million let's say you
attach a compounded annual growth rate
of 30% a year for the next 10 years to
that 200 million I'd like you to guess
how much you will have as revenues 10
years from now so I'll go through the
numbers and I want you to kind of guess
where you end up you think you'll have
half a billion or one billion
two billion somebody with the calculator
can help me out here what happens if you
take 200 * 1.3 ra the^ 8 going to get an
answer right there no you can answer it
yeah you can keep the Exel
open
200.
2.75 by3 billion
right what if
I if you double the growth rate if you
60% inste of 30%
you don't you don't have to give me a
number three billion is what we got with
the 30% growth rate if I double it to
60% where do you think I'll end
up okay 22
billion I want you to remember that we
underestimate the effect of compounding
right so you sit under value company
what do you do you put in a 20% growth
rate for the next 10 years so what's the
big deal 20% growth rate it is a big
deal 20% growth in your company will
triple the size of your company the
question you got to ask is can my
company pulled at all so from a purely
mathematical perspective you look at
growth rates that doesn't look but 20 to
22 how much my suggestion is look at
what it does to your revenues 10 years
out before you decide to start pushing
up the growth rate by another 2% another
4% the effect is going to be a lot
bigger than you realize even if math is
your Forte because the compounding
effect is just
dramatic one final point about growth
right so when you talk about growth
rates you can talk about growth rates in
revenues growth rate in operating income
growth rate in net income growth rate in
earnings per
share yeah and if you look at the growth
rates when you look at those estimates
of growth you see on Yahoo finance or
any of the services which of these
growth rates do you think they're
reporting
I would love it if the revenues would be
rarely useful you know what the most
growth rates what analysts end up
estimating his growth
rates it's earnings per share you saying
so what today we're going to talk about
what happens to growth rates As you move
up the income statement from earnings
per share to net income net income to
operating income operating income to
revenues if you take earnings per share
growth and you make it Revenue growth
you're going to probably quadruple the
value of your company because you've
used the wrong growth rate so we're
going to start that discussion of growth
I wanted to remember the compounding
effect and remember the metric in which
you're Computing growth makes a
difference
so
that do this make me open
theid there go
remember what we left off in the lecture
notes we were talking about dividends
which is what companies actually pay and
potential dividends which is what they
can afford to
pay and for most companies we said
dividends and potential dividends don't
match up so today I want to start off
with a way of thinking about what those
potential Dividends are how do you
estimate how much a company can pay out
in dividends let's start by dispensing
with some Illusions about what what
potential Dividends are I would analysts
argue that earnings are potential
dividends there a couple of problems
with it one is earnings are not cash
flow so you you know you might not even
have the money on hand even though you
report a billion dollars in earnings to
pay it out as dividend second even if
earnings were cash flows if you pay
those earnings out as dividends you're
allowed to do that then your growth rate
has be pretty close to zero right you're
essentially returning everything so I
know analysts sometimes discount
earnings they say earnings are potential
dividends you can't do that especially
if you put in a growth rate because
you're probably double counting the
effect by acting as if the company can
pay out all of its earnings and allowing
the company to grow at the same time so
let me give you my definition of divid
of potential dividends and we'll see how
we can estimate the potential dividend
for a company is the cash left over
after you've met every conceivable need
as a company what are those needs
Capital expenditures working capital
debt payments you go through through the
list the way I like to think about it is
like the old you know most of you don't
have a checkbook you have no idea what
I'm talking about but you have a company
you're making money then you start
writing checks out check to capex check
to working capital check to the debt and
what you're left with in your in your
balance is your potential dividend so
I'm going to concoct a measure that I
concocted know 30 years ago when I wrote
one I'm I called it free cash flow to
equity the CFA kind of took it in it
became a chapter in their book I'll give
you my version of free cash R Equity
you're going to start with net income
and you're going to subtract out what
you reinvest which I measured two items
one is how much you put into capex but
I'm allowing depreciation to offset
against we talked about why we twin the
two it's a net amount that I have to
come up with minus change in working
capital plus the effect of whatever cash
flows are to debt why plus because if I
if I take on Fresh debt it actually acts
as a cash inflow if I repay debt it's a
cash Cash Out flow so if I repay more
debt than I take in then my free cash
Road Equity will go down if I raise more
debt My Free Cash Road Equity will go
it's a potential dividend because I can
pay it out and not hurt myself as a
company remember this is after capex so
after working capital you've reinvested
everything you can there have no other
need for the cash you can take it out of
the company this is a potential dividend
because it you can pay it out without
hurting the company and its value now
now if you look at the line it the items
that go into free cash or Equity
calculation I'll go through the item net
income capex depreciation change in
working capital new debt issues debt
repaid which financial statement am I
most likely to be able to get these line
items will I get them on an income
statement in fact the only item from the
income statement that I can probably get
is net income you won't get capex no
depreciation no working capital it won't
no maybe I can get with the balance
sheet by looking at the change in
balance sheet from year to here but you
go to a statement of cash flows what is
every statement of cash flow start with
what's the first line item n income
right below it will be plus depreciation
and amortization that takes care of half
of the net capex and if you stay in that
section there's change in working
capital so that first section operating
cash flows has net income depreciation
amortization change in working capital
you move to the next section it's
investing activities capex Acquisitions
especially if they're cash Acquisitions
be in there and then you go to the
financing section you're going to see
debt repayments debt issuances every
single item that you need for free cash
Lo Equity is right there that's why I
said estimating potential dividends is
Trivial all you need to do is take the
statement of cash flows pull those items
out now before we go further can a
company a positive net income and end up
with negative free cash Road equity what
has to be true about the company what
what is the company doing that makes it
positive that could be one so if you
have a lot of debt to pay back you're an
lbo right you took on a lot of debt you
got to pay off the debt your free cash
Equity negative what else look at the
items that kind of gives away the clue
very high capex very high capex relative
to depreciation because you have high
capex and high depreciation which a lot
of companies do they kind of offset High
capex relative depreciation which means
you're probably a growing company your
depreciation reflects what you invested
2 3 four years ago now you're much
bigger so high cap X or you might be a
company that's growing with a lot of
working capital
needs you can have positive net income
and negative and let's let's make
dividend policy or you know dividend
assessment very simple if you have
negative free cash FL Equity how much
can you afford to pay
out well don't take too long if you're
in a hold stop digging right you
shouldn't be paying dividends so if you
have ay company negative free cash FL
Equity you shouldn't expect to see a
dividend so free cash flad Equity
reflect what you could afford to pay out
if it's a negative number it means you
got to raise Equity keep going
yes first let's to understand why we
subtract out working capital somebody
explained to me what AC cruel accounting
requires you to do since you ask a
question I'm going to put you on the
spot what is AC cruel accoun requireed
to
do and record transactions as they
happen right so if I sell something on
December 30th I have to show it as
revenues in that year even if I haven't
been paid for it and if I use items from
other years I have to show it as
expenses that year so when I sell
something on December 30th and I record
it as revenues and I haven't been paid
yet what shows up on my balance sheet
reflect the fact that I haven't been
paid
what's the item that you have when when
you've sold something and you haven't
been
paid accounts receivable and if you use
things you haven't paid for it shows up
as accounts payable right what we're
trying to do with change in working
capital coming in is we're converting a
cruel income Into Cash income that's all
that that change in working capital if I
done an entirely cash income statement
you remember what cash income statement
look like I record revenues as I get
paid and expenses as I pay them out
there's no no need for change in working
capital it'll already be cash income so
the reason change in working capital is
in there is to convert convert a cruel
income which is what most of us will
face in our financial statements Into
Cash
income now if you look at a statement of
cash flows one of the nice things about
a statement of cash flows is the sign of
the cash flows already in there right
you know what I mean by that you look at
capex and a statement of cash flows
there'll be a minus in front of it a DE
iation will be a positive a Deb issuance
will be a positive because cash is
coming in a debt repair will be negative
so if you're staying with the statement
of cash flow all you have to do is T
take all those numbers there's no minus
plus all of the numbers already have the
signs on them the cumulative effect will
be the free cash equ so what I'd like
you to do if you're uncomfortable with
that is after class today take your
company I know you picked a company you
told me so pick the last statement of
cash flows and see if you can estimate
the free cash flow Equity loss year just
start simple based on those line
items now my most recent book is called
the corporate life cycle I kind of
mentioned it earlier in class about how
companies move through the life cycle I
want to tie that to what you should
expect to see as free cash FL Equity so
in the life cycle you have startups you
have very young companies you have
growth companies you have maturing
companies you have declining companies
at each stage let's work through what
you should expect to see with those line
items that go into to free cash Equity
you have a startup young or a very young
company what's the N income usually
going to look like if you're a very
young company clear neg it's probably
going to be negative why because you
have expenses but you're not figured out
how to make money yet so you start with
a negative number then let's work on the
reinvestment capex working capital is
that going to be a big number or a small
number it's going to because you're
trying to grow right so you start with a
negative net income you have a big
reinvestment subtractor
even if you have no debt your free cash
load Equity is going to be a big
negative number so when you start up in
Year young company you have a negative
free cash Equity let's move forward
you're now a Growth Company you're now
starting to make money your net income
is now positive this is good news right
but you still have great growth
prospects so you still have lots of
reinvestment so even though you've
started to make money your free cash
flow Equity is probably still going to
be negative but at least moving in the
right direction
what happens as your growth starts level
off this is bad news at one level but
there's good news embedded in here right
if your growth is starting to level off
you look at the line items your net
income is now positive it's growing at a
slower rate but because your growth is
leveled off your reinvestment is now
going to start to get lower your free
cash Lo Equity will go from negative to
positive it's almost essentially it's a
healthy firm you're going to start very
negative free cash Lo Equity negative
free cash Ro Equity positive now you're
a mature firm what happens to a mature
firm you're not growing very much you're
a cash machine you have big net income
very little reinvestment you're at the
peak of your life in terms of free cash
load Equity you're just throwing off
cash enjoy the moment because you're
going to get old you get old what
happens your Revenue start to decline
your margins start to shrink and your
free cash L equi start to go down
again as companies go through the life
cycle you should expect the free cash
load Equity to reflect that so as an
example I took
Tesla there's Tesla's net income and
free cash the green is the net income
and you can see from 2006 which is the
year they were founded through almost
19 the net income was
negative quite small or large amounts
you add on the reinvestment the free
cash Ro Equity is hugely negative in
2020 for the first time you saw net
income free cash Road Equity is actually
close to zero which is a win given the
history and 2021 you saw net income turn
positive and free cash Ro Equity turned
positive as you move through the life
cycle you see the net income and free
cash Equity reflected now of course this
is a happy ending but during this period
what else could have happened to
them per if they' been unable to raise
the capital to keep going this game
could have ended when the free cash FL
Equity were negative so when you value
young company
and you're catching them early in the
life cycle you should expect to see
negative free cash flows in the early
years but if your stories a good one of
improving margins and reduced
reinvestment eventually those free cash
Equity will turn
positive now do you see why a palent
will never pay a dividend or buyback
stock at least in the near
future the more Ambitions you have for
growing at high rates even if you're
making money you're going to be unable
to return it conver
firstly there two companies this year
that initiated dividends for the first
time big name companies two of the ma
seven you know which on started
dividends meta
and Google started paying dividends for
the first time he saying this is bad
news hey this is what happens as
companies succeed and they mature the
signal they're sending is we're not
growth companies anymore you can't send
a stronger signal than that they're
people still out there who think meta
can grow 25% a year 30% a year and the
message there is not happening
guys so as you look at free cash load
Equity it's going to track the life
cycle of the firm and the Dividends are
going to reflect
that so those of you are tracking my
data updates for 2025 I did the debt
update a couple of days ago looking at
how much companies borrow there's one
more data update waiting I can't wait to
get it done to put it behind me it's
going to look at dividends and free cash
Lo Equity dividends versus potential
dividends around the world this is what
the
2020 the last year's numbers look like
so there the by region the number of
firms there a net income there's a free
cash FL
Equity what I call small Asia don't take
it as an insult it's Asia with that
India China and Japan so it's small only
on a relative basis Indonesia has 300
million people but it's small only if
you compare it to a billion 3 right so
that's a small Asia so that's my
breakdown those are the net income in
each of those and you can see that every
part of the world is profitable the
global net income was 5.3 trillion
there's my free cash rate Equity
collectively companies could have
returned 1.63 trillion to shareholders
collectively they returned about 3.9
billion what does that tell me lots of
companies returning what they can't
afford maybe raising fresh Equity to
make up for it but you can look across
the world companies don't always return
what they can afford to free cash flow
Equity so all I do is I go through
Capital like you I take those items net
income capex depreciation change in
working capital all the items you saw
comput the free cash FL equity for every
firm and the divid about 60% of
companies globally return less than
their free cash Equity about 30 comp
about 30% return more and about 10%
return about what they can usual to see
a company return exactly what it
should so free cash Ro Equity is
potential
dividend Dividends are actually what you
know and BuyBacks are what they actually
return there's a shortcut you can use
for free cash or Equity because you
think about forecasting freeastro Equity
think of all the line items you need
right net income capex depreciation
working capital debt issuances debt
repayments to use the shortcut though
you have to be willing to make an
assumption what's the assumption that a
fixed percentage of your reinvestment
always comes from debt because that's
their history 20% of reinvestment comes
from debt because the minute you do that
your free cash Equity calculation
simplifies you start with net income you
subtract out the equity portion 80% of
net capex 80% of change in working
capital you get the free cash Road
Equity because effectively it removes
the need for debt issuances and debt
repayments because of fixed percentage
always comes with that when I have to
forecast freeastro equity for a firm
this is the approach which I prefer
because it means I have to basically
estimate a debt ratio but I can do it
only if you have a company that has a
pretty stable debt ratio and this is
going to come into play later when we
talk about should I be discounting free
cash Lo Equity or free cash The Firm how
easy it is to compute these numbers is
going to be a factor in which one you
choose to
discount so let's try this out I'm going
to go back all the way to
1997 and look at Disney I wanted to
estimate what their potential dividend
could be so I start with the net income
1,533 million the capex was 1746 million
the depreciation was 1,134 Million so
the net capex was about 612 million so
that's what they're reinvesting in
long-term assets the working capital
increased by 477 million
yes
yeah why do they write out, million
because we comparing some companies that
are not in billions but then you have to
put decimals right so you have decide
which one pays you more right so if
every company is a MAG s of course I'm
going to do it only in billions because
they're all you know hundreds of
billions but if I'm comparing steel
companies and three have more than a
billion dollar market Gap and the rest
have less than a billion if I choose to
do it in billions then I'll be writing
decimals for all the companies and
that's a that's a pain in the neck right
so it's better usually to work with
Millions because that way you cover the
whole spectrum of companies and that's
why you stick with Millions but if you
pick Millions stay with Millions don't
go back and forth because that can get
you into trouble so in this case I start
with the net income I subtract out the
612 million but I assume that there at
that point in time that they were
getting 24% of the reinvestment from
debt based on their history so 76% of
the 612 million is My Equity portion of
the reinvestment 7 76% of the 477
million is my working capital
reinvestment you subtract track those
out you get a free cash Road Equity of
million so what can Disney afford to do
they can afford to pay 704 million in
dividends they chose to pay 345 million
if I pause right there you can see
already the danger of the dividend
discount model right in the dividend
discount model I take the 345 million I
value the company as if that's all they
can afford to pay I will undervalue
Disney because they can potentially pay
a lot more I'm already setting the
foundation for if you can compute
dividends in free cash Equity why the
free cash Ro Equity is going to give you
a much more realistic estimate of the
value of equity for a company last year
Google did not pay dividends they
started this year you think they had a
positive free cash Lo Equity last
year absolutely tens of billions of free
cash Road
Equity I've described apple as the
greatest cash machine in history and
here's why over the last decade Apple
has bought back or paid into dividends
about five5
billion but the cash balance is actually
incre oh sorry $500 billion but their
cash balance is actually increased while
they were returning half a trillion
dollars in
cash that's a nice prom to have as a
company so much cash coming in you don't
know what to do with it but that's what
free cash Road Equity is cash available
after every other need has been met yeah
no just why would you discount it it's
cash is cash right so just add the cash
but that's exactly what we do in
valuation is we say you have 200 billion
in cash on the balance sheet I'm just
going to add that on so there's really
no need to discount it unless you don't
trust the management with your cash and
we'll talk about that where you might
discount it because they might do bad
things with the cash
yes I
assume or that's a good question
question I mean capex defined our way
includes Acquisitions it includes R&D it
includes exploration cost so basically
this is our expanded version of capex
when you do free cash Road Equity so the
minute you get through that section on
capex from that point on your definition
of capex will not Converge on what you
see in the statement of cash flows which
makes it tricky if you want to do it for
the last 10 years because then you have
to go back and check for cash
Acquisitions and R&D and adjust for
those to get free cash 2 3 4 5 years
ago exactly exactly
right I'm going to do a little exercise
here and you tell me because it's going
to lead me into a strange place in terms
of what debt does to Value tell me what
I'm missing so when I computed the free
cash flow equity for Disney what did I
do I took the net capex and Chang in
working capital and I multiplied by one
minus the debt ratio right so I said 24%
comes from debt 76% comes from equity
play a little game Let's assume they
taken
40% of their financing of the
reinvestment from debt and 60% from
Equity what would my free cash Lo Equity
look like if more of my money came from
debt and less from
Equity you see my question I'm using a
24% debt ratio what if I used a 40% debt
ratio what do you think is going to
happen it'll be higher tell me why
intuitively what's
happening multiply no no don't give me
the multiplying Factor tell me intu why
it's higher you know what's making my
free cash Equity go up when I borrow
more money it means that I have to come
up with less money on my own right
remember 612 million is my total net cap
X the more I borrow the less I have to
come up with as Equity investors so if I
go to 60% debt my free cash Ro Equity
will go up even more you see where this
is leading me right my free cash Road
Equity will actually increase as my debt
ratio goes from 20% 80% 90 so so as I
borrow more money I've freak this is
good right so if I take this to the next
step what the what would the conclusion
be having more debt should make My
Equity more valuable this is the the
coner what am I
missing once you get down to that income
subract out even if you do that with a
per share basis this this process know
you will always make your net income and
earnings per share Jump by using more
debt but there's something I must be
missing in this puzzle which
is default risk but even without default
rat when you're saying with free cash
Road Equity what's that what do I
discount free cash load Equity at what's
the discount rate I
use that's pause right there right and
what goes into a cost of equity I have a
risk free rate I have an equity risk
premium and I have a beta now do you see
why we connected beta to how much debt
you
have as you look at beta since they L
betas as you borrow more money to fund
this you it's true your free cash Road
Equity will go up but take a look at
what's happening to your beta as you go
from from no debt to 90% debt your cost
of equity will go up so two things are
happening right as I borrow more money
as cash flows I'm feeling much better as
an equity investor but I also have more
risk my discount rate is going up cash
flows are higher my discount rate is
higher so my last question is about the
net effect is debt good for My Equity
value or and I'll give you the
choices the first is increasing leverage
will increase value because the cash
flow effect is going to dominate the
discount rate effect
right the second is increasing leverage
will decrease value because the discount
rate effect will dominate the cash flow
effect the third is increasing leverage
will not affect value because the two
effects will offset each
other and the fourth is any of the above
depending on where you are in the
capital structure of your company in
fact take C that's one of the most
famous theorems in corporate finance
remember that
theorem come on you remember remember
that from good which is meani right what
did meani say it doesn't matter how much
you borrow of course they lived in a
world with no taxes and no default risk
if that's the world you live in then
increasing your debt ratio will have
exactly offsetting effects unfortunately
that's not the world we live in we live
in a world with taxes and with default
risk so can increasing leverage increase
the value of your Equity yes for some
portion but there will be a point where
it's going to turn against you that's
the entire idea of an optimal debt ratio
so if you think about free cash equity
and cost of equity one of the ways you
can decide what the right combination is
to find that combination that maximizes
your value of
equity so free cash flow Equity is an
after debt cash flow and sometimes it
looks like a freebie adding on more debt
will mean more free cash FL Equity but
it always comes with a catch higher risk
in your Equity higher beta higher cost
of equity and the net effect can be a
plus a minus or a zero depending on
where you are in the life
cycle let's talk about growth the key
message I hope to deliver on this growth
component is when you listen to people
talk about growth it's always a good
thing growth is good becoming bigger is
a is is better than shrinking as a
company and I'm going to push against
this I'm going to argue and maybe you
will be on my side after the next 20 or
30 slides that growth can be good for
you growth can be bad for you or growth
can do nothing for you so let's set the
stage when you think about the tradeoff
on growth what's the good side of growth
as you grow your revenues become larger
your income becomes much higher so
that's a good set of growth growth makes
numbers go up but the bad side of growth
is to get that growth you have to
reinvest
money and if you reinvest a lot to get
very little growth you can actually
destroy value as you grow so when you
talk about the value of growth not only
do you have to look at the growth rate
you have to look at how much you're
reinvesting to get that growth it's kind
of a common sense notion we're setting
up for thinking about the value of
growth and evaluation it's not always
going to increase your value for some of
your companies increasing growth will
lower the value of the companies and
what the heck happened your reinvestment
needs are so large to get that growth
that it's not worth it it's not creating
enough value so let's set the stage in
terms of thinking about the three ways
you can estimate growth for your so you
picked your company you're saying what
growth should I use you're now entering
into what I call that discomfort zone
right because you got to make projection
of the Futures I don't know enough I
don't know whether the growth will be 10
or 20 so here are the three places
you're going to go to try to get a
growth rate for your company first is
you're going to look at the
past good place to start right it might
not be a good predictor but before you
make a prediction for the next 10 years
you want to look at the last 10 years if
you have 10 years of data historical
growth the second is you might Outsource
it said look I don't know enough I'm
going to look to see what other people
are estimating as growth for my company
and we live in a world where if you go
go on Google Search and ask what's the
growth rate going to be for meta you
will find 15 different
forecasts nice thing about using
somebody else's forecast you take no
responsibility for your own valuation
it's not my fault I just use the Goldman
numbers the third approach to growth
ties growth to what companies do what
does that mean for a company to grow
it's got to pull off a pretty neat trick
it's got to be able to reinvest a lot
and reinvest well at the same time you
see why this is a trick because most
companies can do one half of that they
can either reinvest a lot but they
reinvest badly or they reinvest well but
not very much to deliver quality growth
you got to do both and maybe by looking
at how much companies are reinvesting
and how well they're reinvesting you can
get Clues as to what future growth is
going to be so let's start with
historical growth because that's usually
the place you start your research right
you have five years of numbers 10 years
of numbers Capital like you you can pull
up numbers for your company going back
in time to As Long for as long as
they've been
around I'm going to argue that while we
take this historical growth rate as a
fact the way you estimate a historical
growth rate can give you wildly
different numbers depending on the time
period you look at and even how you
estimate the growth rate arithmetic
averages compounded averages it'll also
vary depending on the metrics you use
revenues operating income net
income and finally if you have negative
earnings somewhere in the middle it's
going to completely throw you off
getting a percentage growth rate becomes
insanely messy when you have a negative
number going to a positive
number let's let's start this process
right it's a very old example company
called
Motorola five years of number actually
six years of numbers I've revenues I've
Abid die I've EIT for those years I've
computed percentage growth rate each
year so I take the change divide by the
start of the Year number so the
percentage growth rates and I've
computed two averages an arithmetic
average and a geometric average
everybody familiar with the arithmetic
average just add those five numbers
divide by five you get
7.8% how do you compute a geometric
average what's what's the process to get
this 6.82% what did I
do yes
but give me so in this case I want a
mathematical answer
so you take the 3,931 that you have
right now you divide by the 22245 the
starting number that's a total growth
rate and you raise to the power 1/5 why
because you have 5 years of date in the
middle gives you a compounded growth
rate so in the case of revenues the
compounded growth rate was 6.82% the
arithmetic average was 7.08% you're
saying all that work and you just
26% off when you go from revenues to
Abida the arithmetic average becomes 11%
the geometric average becomes 5.39% the
Divergence widens when you go to ear you
know abbit the geometric the the
arithmetic average is 42% the geometric
average is
4.31% and mathematically there's a very
simple reason why as you go from know
revenues to operating income and then to
net income and earnings per share the
difference going to widen it's entirely
a function of how volatile earnings are
I'll give you the example the two
numbers will converge if your annual
growth rate was 8% every year what's
your arithmetic average going to be it's
going to be 8% and if you trust me and
work out the geometric average you get
8% as well the more variation there is
in that percentage growth rate in a
year-to-year basis the bigger the
difference will be between arithmetic
and geometric
averages so when you look up the growth
and earnings for your company you look
up what somebody's estimated growth and
earnings don't take them at their word
you have no idea whether they used an
arithmetic or geometric average and a
geometric average is a much more
reliable indicator of what your company
actually did in fact if you take the
ebit it started at 2.6 billion it ended
at 3.2 billion over a 5year period your
income went from 2.6 to 3.2 billion
there is zero chance that that 42.5%
growth rate you're getting is a
meaningful estimate of what you actually
grew at so arithmetical geometric
averages geometric averages pretty much
went out but you can see that the
Divergence will shift depending on how
volatile earnings
are now let's do a mechanical question
company which has negative earnings 1996
earnings per Shar is minus 5 cents per
share its earnings per share went up to
25 cents in 1997 first is this a good
year or a bad year it went from- 5 cents
to plus 25 cents I'm celebrating right
it's a good deal and ask you to compute
a growth rate for the year how do we
usually compute growth rate what do we
do going to help me minus5 to plus 25 we
take
the you take the change so how much do
you earnings change this year - 5 cents
to plus 25 cents it's a plus 30 Cent and
you're supposed to divide by the
earnings per share last year which is-
20 - 5 C which gives you - 600% you see
what I thought this was a good year and
you're telling me the growth rate is-
600% this is the Havoc that negative
earnings does to you is the growth rates
start to have the wrong sign because the
denominator is negative so give me some
suggestions obviously this makes no
sense what are some of the ways I can
fix
this can I take the minus and just put a
line going the other direction and I
could give you a mathematical reason I'm
using the absolute absolute value of
earnings per share people do that
actually when you have negative earnings
I've seen people use the absolute level
of earnings from last year instead of
minus five they just use 5 cents in
which case you end up with a plus
600% or plus no 250 whatever it works
out the second is that instead of using
the remember the problem comes from
using last year's earnings are negative
so rather than use last year's earning
there people who use a higher of the two
years which would be 25 cents which will
give you 120% growth rate
there are lots of tricks you can play
but the bottom line is when you go from
negative earnings to positive earnings
every single answer you get is kind of
meaningless as a forecast I'm not going
to use the minus 600% I'm not using the
plus 600% I'm not using the 120% the the
real answer is you cannot estimate a
growth rate when you get from negative
to positive so in my spread sheets when
I compute growth rate if the earnings in
the last year is negative I just put nmf
I'd rather treat it as is not meaningful
then attach a number that has no meaning
to it so already you can see historical
growth people treat as a fact but how
you compute the growth in what metric
arithmetic or geometric what you do with
negative earnings can cause variations
in what PE people report is growth for
your
company one final example on historical
growth before let's say you're looking
at a company it's had a great 5year
period it's again a very old valuation
of a company called Callaway
golf there had one product that took
off golf club called the big berther
right exploded out of the box its net
income went from 1.8 million to
122.3mi was 102% a year see this is your
last five years you're the analyst Val C
golf you say hey geometric average
growth rate is 102% I'm going to use
that as my expected growth rate every
year for the next five
years so I'm going to put that in here's
what I get as my expected net income 5
years from now I'd have to have you know
this would basically mean that every
person in in probably in the US has to
buy a big birth of golf club even if
they don't play golf and put it in their
closet because 4.1 billion is kind of
unreachable it's a small Market you
can't get there in order to caution if
you're valuing young growth companies
and you look at their past and you see
30% growth for the Last 5 Years even
though you like the company it's still a
great company should be careful about
what uses your expected growth rate for
the next 5 years because your company
has scaled up it's a bigger company now
than it was 5 years ago so when you
factor in expectations of future growth
the scaling effect has to come into your
forecast so I would suggest you you take
a look at your company's past don't
ignore it but don't get too carried away
don't take those past growth rates and
build your enti entire valuation what
the growth rate has been for the last 3
years The Last 5 Years unfortunately a
lot of financial modeling that's all you
do is you take the past you extrapolate
it it's an extremely dangerous way to do
valuation for all of the reasons we've
talked about so now let's look
at other people's estimate growth rates
now I talked about this early in the
class but I'm going to return to there
are two ways in which Equity re there
are two types of equity research
analysts you have sside analyst and you
have buy side analyst
bisad analysts work for the fideli the
mutual funds of the world so they work
in Summer Street in Boston and they do
research for portfolio management
Fidelity so you never hear about them
you never talk about them because they
they work under the radar salside
analysts work for Goldman Sachs or
Morgan Stanley and you you're usually
given a sector to follow 15 or 20
companies and your job becomes putting
buy or sell recommendations for
companies in the sector so let's say
some of you planning to become saleside
analysts and you know you look at what
you do now if you look at what saleside
analysts do on their jobs a huge amount
of time that saleside analysts spend on
their jobs is in assessing expected
earnings per share it's almost a
fixation and expected earnings per share
next quarter maybe even over the next 5
years so their entire life is spent
these 15 companies forecasting earnings
some of them do forecast earnings for
the next 5 years and many of you will be
able to find an expected growth rate in
earnings per share for your company over
the next five years and you going be
tempted to use it why because these guys
spend all of their time with these 15
companies you've just started to get
acquainted with your company saying they
must know more than I do so an analyst
forecast of growth must be better than
my estimating a growth rate so I'm going
to start with that question analysts
estimate growth for companies they spend
a lot of time on it are their estimates
of growth better than just using
historical numbers and forecasting out
and the results are incredibly mixed
from three different studies and the way
to read this is if this number is a big
number you have a bigger mistake so you
want this number to be as small as
possible the analy it so what this these
studies did was they compare the error
you get in your forecast if you just use
historical data and just project versus
an analyst forecast I'll start with the
good news all these studies concluded
that the analyst error is smaller than
using a Time series model historical
data but the difference is incredibly
small all of the hundreds of millions of
dollars we spend on saleside equity
research for a 3% Improvement in
forecast era and that's for one quarter
ahead if you go to one year ahead two
years ahead five years even that little
Advantage disappear so I have a question
analysts are bright people many of them
went through this class they make they
track these 15 companies that spend
their entire no time analyzing these
companies how come their forecasts are
not much
better before we go to the bad read you
know let's start before we go to the
cynical reasons let's look at you know
what kind of information do analysts
work with that uh you know to make these
forecast it's usually just public
information in the US remember the SEC
has very very strict rules on what
companies it's not like 50 years ago
where and in some parts of the world
this is still true where companies could
give it information analyst that the
rest of the market doesn't have so
analysts in terms of information have a
very small comparative
Edge so it's true they know more about
the company but in terms of information
what they're looking at is very similar
to what you and I are looking at in
terms of 10ks and 10 q's and capital
IQ so first is they don't have much of a
differential second there is an
incentive problem which is they're
trying to make forecast and they caught
up in in all kinds of issues when they
make those forecasts in fact I'm going
to present you some evidence on a
subgroup of analyst because when I
present this I I presented the group of
salside analysts a few years ago and
their defense was it's not us it's those
bad guys driving you know pushing up
making mistakes the best Among Us do
much better at forecasting earning so I
took them at their word and I actually
looked at a group of subgroup of
analysts and this is every analyst
Pinnacle in terms of success is just
like you have all America football teams
institutional investors All America
analyst team so what they do is they go
you know sector by sector Industry Group
by Industry Group picking the All
America analyst of the year and if
you're an equity research analyst and
you get that you're made for life you're
basically this will add an extra zero to
your income from that day on your name
will have all America attached to say
I'm not Joe I'm all America Joe right so
there's actually studies that look at
whether All America analysts are better
at for after all these are the best they
should be better at forecasting ons and
the these studies actually find
something very interesting in the year
before these analysts become all America
analysts they're actually a little worse
than everybody else in forecasting
earnings so the way you make the All
America analyst team must not have
anything to do with forecast error it
must have to do with profile and whether
you get report in the Wall Street
Journal and how you Market yourself the
year
after this is magic they become better
than the average analyst so what do you
think happens right after you become all
americ analyst
sopia that that'll affect the price
impact but you have to improve the
earnings so I agree with you that'll
make mean a bigger price impact but what
makes them better at forecasting
earnings in other words you call the
company right you were plain Joe until
yesterday you called the company they
had no time for you you're all America
Joe you call the same company all of a
sudden people are willing to leak out
little pieces of information to
you information access right that
private information that is on the right
side of the legal at least you hope on
the right side of the legal line you get
more access to information and it is
true when you make a recommendation now
you have a much bigger impact on the
stock
price but more for sell recommendations
than buy recommendations a typical buy
recommendation stock goes up about 3%
know on sell recommendation stock goes
down 4.7% wor still if you track the buy
recommendations for about 3 months after
the buy recommendation the 3% actually
drops off to 2.4% the sell
recommendation the 4.7% becomes
13.8% so if you think about it buy
recommendations have a smaller impact
than sell recommendations
and sell recommendations are far greater
staying power how do you explain that
difference why are buy recommendations
so much less
eff that's the first thing there are
nine times as many buy recommendations
as a sell recommendation so that's the
first thing second is which is easier to
give as an equity research analy what
makes your life easier we talked about
buyers buyer recommendation the fact
that an equity research analy is willing
to put a sell recommendation on a
company means that he must or she must
feel much more intensely about it then
on a buy
recommendation so do equity research
analysts affect stock prices with their
recommendations on average yes more with
sell than with buy recommendations
yeah well if it were that easy then we'd
all be making money selling short on
companies so I'm not sure there is that
Loop it might happen in some companies
but it's not the it might be the
exception rather than the rule right
because if if that was always the case
you need to do is pick companies in the
spiral sell short and you make tons of
money so some companies you might be
right but not
collectively so I've thought about this
for a while as I said I have more
students who become saleside equity
research analyst than probably any other
single group of
jobs and cide equity research is sick at
the moment it's broken so I thought
about some of the reasons why I think
salside equity research analysts are in
the trouble that they are and here are
some one is what I call tunnel vision
how do I say sside equity research is
structured you're hired by Goldman Sachs
then you given a
sector you're boring newspapers it could
be utilities and then what are you told
to do stay focused just on these 15
companies your entire life is those 15
companies see where the tunnel vision
comes from you're tracking AI companies
paying 40 times revenu that's what
everybody does don't they mean your
companies that's what they do that's the
tunnel vision part the way we've
structured cide equity research is we've
designed these these these these roles
where you have absolutely no big picture
second is leming
itis what is lming itis if you have know
there are companies like you know Nvidia
where there are 65 analysts tracking the
company if you get a chance take a look
at what happens when one analyst puts
out uh you know you you're allowed to
revise earnings upwards so inv earnings
I think come due November 26th day after
tomorrow so if an analyst comes out
today and say I'm going to increase my
earnings estimate by five sets you know
what'll happen within an hour about 20
15 or 20 of the other analysts will also
join so I too am doing it why you don't
be left out that's a leming itis third
is a version of what I call the
Stockholm syndrome you heard of
Stockholm syndrome right it's named
after this re very real phenomenon the
1970s
where people were taken hostage and
after a while started identifying with
their hostage takers more than the
people who might rescue them Stockholm
say what's that got to do with cide
equity research the original idea of
cide equity research you were supposed
to be outside the firm looking
objectively at the company asking tough
questions about the company instead
though many of these s side analysts
have become so close to the company that
they can't step back they think their
job is to defend the company
like those hostages you know identifying
with the hostage
takers if you get a chance also pick up
a sell side equity research report you
can find them online pull it up it's
amazing how many stories you hear that's
good right stories these are stories
with no numbers they just basically make
up story after story after Story a
creative
novelist and finally and this is less of
a problem now than 20 years ago but it's
still a problem if you're a sside equity
research analyst who works at government
Sachs and you're tracking let's say
meta and you feel this urge to put a
cell recommendation on meta does Goldman
Sachs have other business that they do
with
meta probably invest in banking business
they might have IPOs that might come out
so you're probably going to get a call
if not explicitly there supposed to be a
Chinese wall but that Chinese wall has
lots of holes you climb up and round and
go you're going to get a call from
somebody saying that sell recommendation
on met is probably not a great idea
because it'll hurt our other business
and there was a time in the late '90s
where there were cide equity research
analyst who thought their job was to
bring in business for the investment
bank and one of the most famous was this
guy called Jack grubman maybe the worst
saleside analyst I've ever seen but the
guy was incredibly Rich he was an all
America analyst every year because his
name was always in the news but Jack
thought his job was not just to be a
saleside analyst but to bring in
investment banking business to the
company in fact it's the reason Elliot
Spitzer in the early part of this
Century targeted investment Banks
because he said there's a conflict of
interest here where you're putting out
recommendations that you don't and
investment bankers were stupid enough to
put out buy recommendation then send out
emails to each other saying that's a
really stupid stock to buy and leave it
on a server so he's able to pull that
all up and say you put a buy
recommendation to clients same time
you're passing these internal messages
telling yourself that this is a ter
company that's said Dr Jackel and Mr
high now I wonder whether cide equity
research can be rescued to be quite
honest because I think the differential
advantages you had 40 or 50 years ago in
terms of information and data and tools
is now
gone I'm not sure what you bring to it
in fact I ask portfolio managers this
question all the time why do you listen
to cide equity research analyst their
recommendations have no staying value
and the only answer I get is the very
best sside equity research analysts
understand the business it's not even
the buy and the sell recommendation they
understand the semiconductor business
they've been around they've seen how it
evolved they can give me a narrative
about how the business is changing that
I would not get and I agree with that
there are that when I talk to saleside
analy I have zero interest in their buys
and sells I said don't tell me tell me
what you think about the retail business
because the really good salside analyst
who's been in this business for long
enough can give you insights about the
business that you can use when you value
individual retail companies so I'm not
saying don't listen to sside analyst but
definitely don't look at the buys and
the sells they give you no information
but maybe the narrative about a company
or a business can be useful when you
start to value a
company so here are the three core
propositions first if you think those
cide analysts know a great deal more
than you do let it go there's very
little private information that analysts
have that you don't have you're not at a
massive disadvantage relative to Goldman
Sachs analyst on your
company much of that private information
comes from the firm and it's
biased it's like having being a
journalist and a politician is your main
source you should expect that
information you get from the politician
to be unbiased they're going to
basically spin their way spun so even
the private information you get from the
company tends to be biased but there's
there's a reason therefore that you know
All America analyst then gets a little
better information because they have
better access and
finally and this is the bottom line I
made there is value to knowing what
analysts think about your company I'm
not saying there's no value so if you
look at your company and there are five
sell recommendations and a buy
recommendations that's a pretty negative
view of the company now I'm not saying
that should mean your view has to be
negative as well but that might have to
be factored in when you tell when you
think about the story you tell about
your company so but don't take that
growth rate whether it's a analyst or
managers or anybody else and use that in
your valuation because if you do it's
not your valuation it's not your
story incidentally a variant of this
Outsourcing of growth rates happens in
private company valuation you know in
private company valuation I've never
understood this process you know why you
get your earnings and cash flows you
don't estimate them you get them from
the managers of the company that you're
appraising for
value and what do you think those cas
and cash flows look like in terms of
buyers man companies Supply the numbers
they're going to be much higher
especially on a high
value and and the appraisers know
this and to counter it what they do is
they take the discount rate and they
start adding things to it to make it a
higher number it's an incredibly
destructive process because both the
cash flows and the discount rate become
almost meaningless at this point in time
they're gaming the system the analysts
keep increasing the cash flow I'm sorry
the the managers keep increasing the
cash flows the analysts keep increasing
the discount rate I don't know how this
game even
ends but if you let other people Supply
you with the future cash flows the
growth rates and the you've lost control
of the story you it's not your valuation
in any real
sense so we got historical growth we've
talked about analyst growth let's talk
about the third way you can estimate
growth incidentally this is not on your
quiz so you can relax none of the growth
things are on your quiz it's up to to
cash flows right I know you're some of
you saying oh my God no this is this is
too much I can't get ready on this so if
you look at the earlier quizzes there
was a growth problem in all of the
earlier quizzes this quiz we're going to
stop with free cash Ro Equity so the
part that we were in but let's talk
about what it is that drives
growth let's start with a very simple
exercise let's suppose you have a
company with a billion dollars invest in
existing projects earning a 12% return
so basically 12% of a billion is 100 $20
million that's its current earnings
let's assume next year the company
invests in 100 million in new projects
on which it continues to make a 12%
return if you look at the earnings next
year it's going to be 120 + 12 132
million trust me there's a point to this
if you look at the growth rate they had
in the next year their income went from
120 to 132 million it's a 10% growth
rate and that increase in income came
entirely from new Investments earning a
12% return
if you have a company with a stable
return Equity the only way it can grow
is by increasing its Equity Base by
reinvesting money in fact if you were to
write this out mathematically you could
actually see that their reinvestment is
a 100 million they put back as a
percentage of the total net income the
return they made was 12% 12% time 83.33%
gives me a 10% growth rate this is
called sustainable growth people use it
all the time in valuation but I want you
to see where it comes from it comes from
assuming a stable accounting return in
which case the only way you can grow is
by increasing your investment Base by
reinvesting more money but already you
can see potential leakages right if I
can increase the return in equity from
12% to 133% on my existing projects can
I still
grow 1% higher return Equity without
reinvestment so if you can improve your
return Equity we'll call it efficiency
growth you can grow without reinvestment
but if you want to grow with the same
return Equity you have to add to your
base so every sustainable growth
equation will have this reinvestment
rate how much do you reinvest back and
how well do you
reinvest how you measure the
reinvestment rate and how well you
reinvest depends on which model you use
remember we talked about the dividend
discount model the Free Cash Road Equity
model and the free cash of the firm
model if you're staying with the
dividend discon model your reinvestment
rate is measured as the retention ratio
the percentage of net income that you
put back into the company one minus the
payout ratio and the quality of your
Investments is measured with the return
in equity n because everything is an
equity terms if you're looking at free
cash Road Equity then the reinvestment
you're measuring is what you actually
put into the company it's net capex and
change in working capital coming from
Equity
investors as a per of net income and the
quality of your projects will be what I
call non-cash return and Equity the net
income you make from your non-cash
assets you you take out the interest
income from cash and your book Equity
will have cash netted out because you're
looking at what do I make on my non-cash
assets and finally if you're looking at
operating income your reinvestment rate
will be what do you put in in terms of
net capex and change in working capital
as a percentage of operating income and
the quality of your projects you measure
with the return on invested Capital
you're going to see this number This
this term pop up often in this class
return invested capital is what you in
invest what you earn on all of your
Capital return equity and return
invested Capital are the only places in
finance where we stay with Book value
numers so the return Equity is net
income divided by book Equity the return
on capital is net income divided by Book
value of equity plus book value of debt
minus cash and that puzzles people
because everywhere else in finance what
was the room always use market value so
I have a question and I you know I want
you to think about the because this is a
question that I often don't get the
right answer on why do we stay with Book
value in Computing return in equity and
return invested
capital in other words if I want to
measure the quality of a project company
what do I do I look at what you put into
a project let's say you put in 30
million let's say if you make 15 million
as income on it that's great right you
pick great projects I give you a 50%
perc return Equity the market looks at
you what does it say 15 million it's a
good company they give you a market
value of 120 million why because the 15
million every year is going to be worth
120 million if I replace Book value of
equity with market value of equity every
company will have a return Equity
roughly equal to its cost of equity
because in a sense I'm making every
company an average company the reason we
look at return equity and return inv
capital is we want to look at the
quality of the existing Investments the
company and we're hoping and praying
that book value captures why hoping and
praying you're completely dependent on
accountant for both numbers who measures
earnings accountants do who measures
Book value accountants do you're saying
so what every time accountants do
something weird you're going to feel the
effects I'll give you an example if you
make a mistake as a company on a project
you took two years ago what are
accountants train to do if it's a
mistake that everybody accepts as a
mistake
write it off let's so let's say you
write off two billion that's the right
thing to do right when you write off two
billion what happens to your book value
right after that it's going to drop by
two billion and if a year later I didn't
realize You' done this and I compute the
return equity and return invested
capital for your company you're going to
look great I'm going to conclude you
took great projects when in fact you
took terrible projects and you kept
writing off your
mistakes we're going to come back to
this notion of return invested capital
and talk about all the fixes you you
have to do make it more sensible but for
better way it becomes at proxy for how
good are your Investments as a company
and you can see why it plays hard in
growth if you have a high return on
Capital you benefit in one of two ways
you can either get the same growth rate
with a much lower reinvestment which
means you can take more cash out or you
can grow at a higher rate with the same
reinvestment because that return on
capital is adding so as you look at fun
sustainable growth those become the
proxies that you base that sustainable
growth on
so let's start with expected growth in
earnings per share when would you use
this maybe you're using a dividend
discount Model A Bank is a good example
you're trying to estimate dividends per
share for the next 5 years you say what
will earnings per share go it's going to
be a product of return in equity and the
retention ratio retention ratio is the
percentage of net income that you leave
in the
business so uh in the special case where
our return Equity remains unchanged
there's your sustainable growth grow
equation for the growth ear retention
ratio times return Equity what's the
highest retention ratio can be what the
highest percentage of your net income
you can hold 100% right in this equation
your expected growth cannot exceed your
return Equity because most you can do is
have a retention ratio of 100% so in
dividend discount models this is the way
you see things play up so I'll take a
company 2008 I was looking at Wells
Fargo just before the financial crisis
bad timing in terms of looking at the
company and its return in equity was
17.56% Banks were doing very well and
its retention ratio was about
45% in my June of 2008 valuation of wels
Fargo you take the product of those two
numbers
17.46% you get an expected growth in
earnings per share of 8% implicitly what
I'm assuming I'm assuming they're going
to be able to to maintain that return
equity and keep paying out about 54% of
their earnings as dividends or retaining
45% what can go wrong everything in fact
what did the 2008 crisis do it hammered
their return Equity return Equity drop
it also brought up regulatory Capital
ratios which effectively means you got
to maintain more book book Equity so if
you look at what can happen to these
numbers every single one of these
numbers you're telling a story about the
company and here the story was they can
keep doing what they're doing which
turned out to be in hindsight to be an
unrealistic
story in fact um when you when you think
about that return Equity number this
will be the last thing for today there
are two ways you can end up with a high
return
Equity one is to go take great projects
Nvidia is an incredible return Equity
why it's an amazing company now what can
you say but there's a second way in
which you can end up with a high return
Equity you can take average projects
and pump up your return Equity by
borrowing a ton of money you see why
borrowing can increase your return
Equity let's say you make 8% on a
project you borrow money at 5% and you
have a 40% tax rate in effect you're
borrowing money at 3% you borrow money
3% you put in the project that makes 8%
you claim that difference for yourself
as an equity investor fact you could if
you break down the return Equity turns
out that the return Equity can be broken
down into return on Capital which is
what you'd have earned with no debt plus
a debt effect so the more debt you have
the higher the debt to equity ratio and
the item in the brackets captures that
benefit of using cheap debt to take
great
projects here in real estate this has
basically been the real estate model for
as long as real estate has been around
real estate is a very average business
what what do I mean by that if you look
at rental income on properties you look
at the return you make 6% 7% 7 and a
half%
you know how Real Estate Investors end
up with a 30 40 50% return Equity is
they use a ton of debt and if you can
borrow money at less than 7 and a half%
you get a tax benefit on top of it you
can take that 7 and a half% return on
Capital and make it a 30 or a 40 or a
45% return and Equity so when you think
about companies High returns and Equity
it's worth pausing and asking why is my
return Equity high is it because I took
great projects or because I took average
projects and pumped it up put that which
should which would you rather be the
answer if you're an invest potential
investor in the
company and show me where it shows up
that when I take that I get let's say I
get the same return equity for two
companies one got there by taking great
projects the other got there by
borrowing a ton of money and pumping up
average projects where in my
valuation will that show
up it'll show when you have return
Equity what do you compare it to your
cost of equity
right the first company took no debt so
it's cost of equity is going to be very
close to its UNL beta cost of equity the
second company took a ton of debt its
cost of equity is going to be much
higher so when people claim my return
equity and private Equity investors do
this all the time and they're selling
their their their wees we can make a 35%
return Equity before you let them go
further the question you got to ask is
how much debt are you taking on because
the 35% return Equity might look great
until I realize you're using 400% debt
for every you know $4 of debt for every
dollar of equity
so when you look at return Equity that's
something to kind of factor in so let's
let's finish that because I don't want
to know go on to the next one we've seen
we've done enough today so I will see
you on Wednesday we're going to complete
the discussion of growth but as I said
growth will not be on the next Quiz
it'll just be through cash flow
don't Pi up my
that mean last time they did this it
took me forever to actually get
recording I kept recording
yeah that
m
nor
um it's warm and I wor a kind goose and
a Nike sweater and I'm like sweating my
ass $600 of Canada it's it's counter
it's counter
what are your
thoughts New York what are your thoughts
[Music]
they
right
[Music]
che check one two
check one two check check one
two people like
they
had and would not tell people to
Charlotte York I grew up the upper side
so like there's no way I would go to
Charlotte no they changed it this year
they're sending
problem the risk
itself
Che one two
B
thank you are you making them up yeah
sure I'll make them up
so why do you take
something
spe
gonna cross fingers and toes and make
sure all right you have two guests today
there they are yes hello how you doing
PA Mauricio helping us with technology
and other things
get yourself between and
I'll yeah are welcome to I will
[Music]
than
e
e e
Joseph can I chest mic
five
just
right number five it's on
um turn auto auto mic mix
off
okay good
but we're okay we're good we're good
so bu
[Music]
theirs in our
services sofware enabled Services some
of
those like I was thinking of it I was
like maybe we can try so
not a program but St
exp
yeah yeah
all
ACH of service lines most of
them they do a ton of research
consolidation they tell you what
a lot
of yeah a lot ofch
uh the research is usually one
level some of them have degrees some of
them value
become
L places
are
and
so uper
even
just
whole yeah
people
prot
[Music]
think
you
I
yeah
for
for e
spe
spe e
all right good
afternoon
hey hey Joseph bring the lights down
again all right good afternoon and
welcome
back Professor younger Professor
younger we're starting on time here come
on in find a seat uh we'll just uh
invite you all to uh settle in welcome
back again this is your second time here
in this room so welcome back to you for
the second time uh I uh was telling uh
our guests today that yes yes be here on
time if you're not on if you're not
early you're late right Mark uh um I was
telling our guests uh that indeed all of
you people have just been working really
hard this weekend to kind of turn in
those papers last night so kind of
feeling the the effort uh that that
you've expended uh my hope is that that
effort uh will come to that that there's
already some an end in itself an
intrinsically motivating aspect to
trying to make sense of something with
Amazon what we've been doing I'll tell
you uh we're orienting here toward and
again we can hear you down here laughing
in the back please uh bring your voices
down to to sort of allow others to hear
uh we're orienting ourselves to unit two
uh and to a series of plenary sessions
on systems that connect business and
Society uh globally I'm going to start
with a little bit of presentation of
some global data some sort of risks and
costs and then a local illustration to
connect you people with the uh yes the
challenges and opportunities please
please
the semester we're in unit two uh I said
that already uh you've just they what
they've all been doing the first uh four
weeks of the semester is focusing on
Amazon as an illustration of the
complexity of the relationship between
business and Society so we've had this
is not news to you but it's news perhaps
to our guests uh what is a platform
business model how does that tilt Market
positioning for better for worse
antitrust prosecutions and such uh then
labor rights uh the last people to
occupy these chairs were representatives
of the Amazon labor union uh organizing
out of
jfk8 so uh we transition from that
single firm illustration to uh indeed a
a a focus on Global Systems that should
uh we'll see we'll see bear upon all of
the topics that you choose to write
about in units 2 and three again that's
a big feature of the design of the
course uh everybody was basically
writing the same paper uh in unit one
you'll all be choosing your own paper
topics in units two and three and so the
idea is that these systems whatever
topic you choose Energy Systems
Financial